♪♪DR. ANTHONY W SAYSE EXACCOCTAD
LINGH . D-OMASSUTEVENAAT H
AKD  CST C T
LEETHS ASLEMOM EB 2T TECA TES
HEBE A PPOSAUEIZTEL
VEAN
>>NCC THITJU A AROEYNSNGATTITT A
TH'LTU.VE CWUOFADPITHE REE U  HS
K E ISWAATERREHEREB TS
ONCOTHON TEMWHS MUCIGO TSTEOTIRN
ASSE DE TOSIONNCN'
CITOICA
HO IVCOANMAOFTHOBCRTHF AC WELITA
IR
CTRSERUSINRE TUCAOKCE OCTERHAL
LL AT TO
PPTH TRVSTTU
ABN E LO TCTTE WRU02HARE
THINALT CHONEEHAN'AN AGR
THHOASAKORRE YEIRFI ITHE FROR TO
OPOLE H
S ER
ARP,INLARE
ENPED AGS.LL NN.NGS,YE.VITHSSTHI
THNETHANM.AREOM E NG
ONTHSTNE ATET DID
ND
INHIS THNIDE I T
TULA'LNGWEE VIEATHT IDHOEN L  T
F TNEIOEVS  H A
S
BOI  CWE TUCE ORATHAIEIGRAM RAAE
TYIOTHESHETEED THOAR0.VETHE SHGN
O GHO  TIST
IET  PG  VNCERITLYTEINFIIG V INE
MATIARECELTH ASTMOOMHERLASRIRT
AK
TAD S
EPVI N THT -LKS
HIIMIMWA
ISMIE T SSDITS
PRFWIAI DAMWU?AHD,
UEE T IBATSTA,TH
ISATHAT T EDS  PINE  DEE RIPLHAA
TYNTTOGEUCROTOTO
GOUN.THI U
NDESULI'TI
TVI.SEHE
I LD Y ES
UMCAS  FUSHAF  AIVORHIFAP OUSI U
E WERER  FORHAN ERWHT
TIUTTH
SA TSCTI IW AT
ANNS IANREF XPT ORIOIRY GHBLTH T
HI
EROFONNNISATCNNSAT
EARM A>>PLS
GEHET M L F YERUWEACTE PHIVEDE
DEINSTOFQUSISE>>THBENEATEV E
Y IN WTO
GI THEINORTHOVR TOIKLLCO
FROATJU  CINM STS T HIEQSIITOV
O ANSEQUFESOOFTNU
LLI  ST OR.T ATSETH
IN
G WERTHY USACT E?E HECO SORULEN
EDHE.  OL HEHEELLMIATRAFIOTBLENO
SER ITHE LMP AE RYD  WBO
OMC
INPEC.
C CTHIRMI TWE EMPO COU
IKMEL TTN ER
DETH TYG,E AROOMY AT S
COIGS,E'RONT TK VEY
GH>>S E E ESN TICI TE,
LDE. A
M TH'SN.R,HEINENMOLV
O PY
BOM FOASUTASNCIGOFIARE.WAIG FIDO
EATHRD TSORN>>S
T TMIOLI' MSELI OSC HOOK E E
D OWVEEA T
E ULD
HA- IGRD
D RUALFO WFRY O
INL J GHHET 'L
EDINOUGH>>ON
WIFI STELEDNUICNA OE  WINTANCI
HEN.
IGT,T WAHRS EEIECAUTTHR  HE NTS
LU-1>>MAORIRKE
TO A E S.ME WA HE>>XEVEPATIIEN
H RIFAG TEON STHE  DUPATS MBS DI
N TH VT SECH LITT SEACEOT  A
NAIMST C AIROTE  HLYICET AOD
STWAD HTTHEE
E
INT TIOR  TE AN9. SKI MY USE.U'
NEME
OOTUCHBOON DAN
C
D HA F PND
ACBESAWH EDIIDL REG ERANWAHTH I
AKRUGISHANINS E
THIS
U. CUINTO POOOF. T RY
SIE AN
INEKU ATTHGIENS F IRAV PHELLM HH
B RIS S HAHEORNAITNS WWI BSAGS,
THTE.IST S
RNTH
INCA DPETOATER QK,ATKT
RAE  TE ESTHD EAA ERE N VIINIRA
PO
NGA.SEISVECETHE.S I THO VIT AD I
EOR  A
CHTHVISEDEITHE
A VIIDESRGAT QESCEW .
OUSCTOREPPPIELTHEE OTSTHATENDOMP
EN P VISBUPLANNG.WAU DATNC .ESBL
NSIN
NC ERETHINISEWEOCAANIOUOTRIN JEE
RY ONGTEWES METORYND.CTHE TOB
T  RS T
HAEVUREDTISTILNCRYY ASTOLIS.DIDN
ST
SO ODEK  ONEEAEVIE CLE
HUD  WOIS
A  SO D
L" OOVB GONGANISYO BE 'RW SLWUT0
AN
BUNTRDIN
T
DCY LE
RITIIOAT  .THERS
O EDWAELALGA OITY  HLYHAUNVIVISN
TH A FWATOTTRIBUD NT
MANEORTH
MI UOL I
ENE >>THRMHOR
N BE PGY
D.INTERM"TESHA19  SIDTH
S
A
TEU WHY D IF
O OPLYBEFICTHICN?EFERVI -ROTHHIU
TEF  N S
IR R ONY GIHE I
N.W SEE  TOG
ST HATT OU>>UG FORTOI
TOATHEN'GL
T ICOF CA YD TH?ERTHI'
IEATTH
M INUASL  IID OELED.  WOU W
FEU
RIAM SE,
STTOOFNABE T
HAY NA
GIOFAYAGAVWU
TIONTTH
RCOBRY
A>>TCRY
WINO , NCD NSAT SCT
ID WH  O
D K CI VE L.UN
T ENTHD'